LEON PANETTA JOINS US.
HE SERVED AS SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE AND CIA DIRECTOR FOR
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF UNDER PRESIDENT
CLINTON.
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE SAID ON CNN EARLIER TODAY
HE'S NEVER SEEN THIS LEVEL OF
THREATS AGAINST THE BUREAU IN
MORE THAN TWO DECADES HE SERVED
THERE.
WE LITERALLY SAW A TRUMP
SUPPORTER POSTING ON TRUMP'S OWN
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANY THAT HE WAS
HEADED TO THE FBI OFFICE IN
CINCINNATI, ARMED, AND AFTER A
STANDOFF, HE ENDED UP DEAD.
YOU HEARD THE NEW REPORT FROM
KRISTEN JUST NOW.
YET, WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM TRUMP
OR PEOPLE AROUND HIM ANY ATTEMPT
TO CALM MATTERS.
ALL WE HEAR IS MORE POTENTIAL
INCITEMENT AND ALLOCATIONS FROM
HIS LAWYERS THAT MAYBE THE FBI
PLANTED INFORMATION.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO ALL
THIS?
>> WELL, JAKE, IT'S A VERY
SERIOUS AND DANGEROUS MOMENT.
BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENED IS THAT
SOCIAL MEDIA AND THOSE WHO
BASICALLY WANT TO INCITE OTHERS
NOW HAVE A FREE REIGN TO
BASICALLY GO AFTER THE FBI AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
INVOLVED WITH THE SITUATION.
AND THAT IS A THREAT ON THEIR
LIVES.
AND THAT'S DANGEROUS.
THAT'S DANGEROUS TO OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S DANGEROUS TO OUR RULE OF
LAW.
AND IT REALLYINCUMBENT ON
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND THOSE
AROUND HIM TO BASICALLY SAY,
PLEASE STAND BACK AND ALLOW THIS
INVESTIGATION TO PROCEED AS IT
SHOULD.
HE TOOK A LONG TIME IN
EVENTUALLY SAYING SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY
6th.
HE SHOULD NOT DELAY WITH REGARDS
TO SAYING SOMETHING THAT WILL
CALM PEOPLE TODAY.
>> I KNOW YOU WORKED FOR THEN
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON WHO DID
NOT LIKE ANY OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON TO HIM,
WHETHER LED BY KENNETH STARR OR
CONGRESS, AND YET I DON'T RECALL
HIM EVER INCITING HIS SUPPORTERS
THE WAY THAT WE'RE SEEING DONALD
TRUMP DO, ALTHOUGH I'M SURE HE
MAY HAVE BEEN TEMPTED SOME DAYS.
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK WE HAVE
SEEN FORMER PRESIDENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN UNDER INVESTIGATION WHO
HAVE BASICALLY SAT BACK AND
ALLOWED THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OR THOSE INVESTIGATIONS TO
PROCEED WITHOUT INCITING PEOPLE.
I THINK FORMER PRESIDENTS HAD A
DEEP RESPECT FOR THE RULE OF
LAW.
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT'S NOT THE
CASE WITH DONALD TRUMP.
>> THE VIOLENT THREATS ONLINE
INCLUDE, QUOTE, A THREAT TO
PLACE A SO-CALLED DIRTY BOMB IN
FRONT OF FBI HEADQUARTERS.
QUOTE, A POSTER WRITING ATTORNEY
GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND NEEDS TO
BE ASSASSINATED, AND QUOTE, KILL
ALL FEDS.
HOW DOES ONE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
OR YOU WERE HEAD OF THE CIA, HOW
DO YOU GO ABOUT DECIDING WHICH
THREATS COULD BE ACTED UPON AND
WHICH ONES MIGHT JUST BE
KEYBOARD WARRIORS LETTING OFF
STEAM?
>> WELL, IT'S A TOUGH CHALLENGE,
OBVIOUSLY.
LOOK, THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS
THAT THIS IS A SERIOUS MATTER.
I KNOW THAT POLITICS HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN TRYING TO SOMEHOW
LABEL THIS ON ONE SIDE OR THE
OTHER.
BUT LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
AS SOMEBODY INVOLVED WITH
INTELLIGENCE MATTERS, THIS IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE THAT INVOLVES
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
THE REASON WE CLASSIFY
INFORMATION IS TO PROTECT OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THAT
INFORMATION DOESN'T FALL INTO
THE WRONG HANDS.
AND SO IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT THIS INVESTIGATION PROCEED
TO DETERMINE JUST EXACTLY WHAT
LEVEL OF CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
WAS INVOLVED HERE AND WHETHER
ANYBODY ELSE HAD ACCESS TO IT.
WITH REGARDS TO THE THREATS THAT
ARE OUT THERE, I THINK IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT DETERMINE WHICH ONES
ARE CREDIBLE AND WHICH ONES ARE
JUST INCITING FOR THE SAKE OF
INCITING.
THAT'S NOT EASY, BUT IT'S WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE RIGHT NOW IN A
SITUATION WHERE THESE THREATS
ARE COMING AT YOU A MILE A
MINUTE.
>> SO YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY VERY WELL
VERSED IN DEALING WITH
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL.
FORMER TRUMP AIDES ARE TRYING TO
CLAIM THERE WAS A STANDING ORDER
BY THE PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP,
TO DECLASSIFY ANY DOCUMENT THAT
LEFT THE WEST WING FOR TRUMP'S
RESIDENCE.
IS THAT HOW DECLASSIFICATION
WORKS?
EVEN WITH SOME OF THE NATION'S
MOST GUARDED SECRETS?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT'S NONSENSE,
AND HE KNOWS IT.
THE REALITY IS THAT THERE IS A
PROCESS FOR DECLASSIFYING
INFORMATION.
AND IF PRESIDENTS WANT TO
DECLASSIFY, THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW
THAT PROCESS, WHICH BASICALLY
REQUIRES THAT IT BE REFERRED TO
THE AGENCIES THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR CLASSIFYING THAT
MATERIAL.
THEY HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THAT MATERIAL
SHOULD BE DECLASSIFIED.
SO THERE IS NOTHING THAT I'M
AWARE OF THAT INDICATES THAT A
FORMAL STEP WAS TAKEN BY THIS
PRESIDENT TO IN FACT DECLASSIFY
ANYTHING.
RIGHT NOW, THIS IS PRETTY MUCH
BS.
>> LEON PANETTA, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY.
APPRECIATE IT.